all right I think I'll be giving our
first lightning talk I'll give you a
five-minute time but with one minute
right
[Applause]
that's why we call it tough to follow
thank you very much for letting me
impress end here I'm a master's student
over at Cass Business School this is my
dissertation topic on in forecasting
structural brakes first of all who hear
on any cryptocurrency Bitcoin oh so few
hands up already pretty sure you have
like a heart attack every 10 minutes so
that's the idea of it that's the
interest lies that I want you know when
do the price surge or when did the price
job like dramatically most unexpected
way so the methodology I used as a type
of unsupervised learning hid the Markov
model if anyone knows basically they
used a bow Welch algorithm with
expectation-maximization algorithm to
give the free
matrixes the the point of interest is
the transition matrix basically it just
it contains the transition probabilities
of the time series searching States
there's no analytical solutions to the
optimum states so you need to test it
out which is what kind of a job at what
hidden Markov model so I fear lies this
as a way to define the current state of
the market you can see in this flow
chart we have the features of the market
that could be like bit us Brett there
could be implied the cross rate
arbitrage so we realized that the
feature the features have predictive
market to the market to the market and
the change in the transition matrix sort
of give us we'll call trading signals or
alpha signals you can see in the middle
that's basically the pipeline to
transition matrix it's fat-free and then
we back test this algorithm so you have
a really simple trading strategies if
the transition probably goes up really
long and short vice versa so we I
started tested on the crypto currency
markets this is the back testing results
for a month we used five minutes data as
you can see that most of the portfolios
on a below they are having like an
overfitting problem and the in table you
have the first fire or the five best
performing portfolios they all have a
positive alpha positive info ratio
information ratio these are for folio
performance matrixes which which is good
in instinct but then we look at the the
underlying classifier or the underlying
transition matrix so if you look at the
confusion matrix look at the precision
recall that they don't read profound
that well when you compare to the random
guessing except one which is predicting
there's no break at the week at the
recoil rate so we're off not not a good
start already then for any comp back
testing you need to do it for a
different market conscious focus on the
crypto currency especially when you're
only training the Bitcoin dollars which
is the best performing ones the etherium
the repo didn't read the benchmark when
in turn to a more traditional market the
Forex one it's the problem reason is it
got even worse all the performance
portfolio performance metrics in store
negative which is not ideal basically
they didn't beat the benchmark when you
look at the confusion matrix ease or the
precision recall they all behave they
behave the same way as the
cryptocurrency one so scratching my hat
was what went wrong like any researcher
I saw come up with like further
improvements or mr1 mistakes or no one
learned so far is that the first of all
they're hyper parameters tunings the the
hidden Markov model is essentially they
re susceptible to the the fitting room
window if you have an imbalance sample
it means that you can't really determine
debate the baseline for the hidden
Markov model then you also have the
trading rules maybe it's too simple will
always trade on a fixed and mal
maybe the underlying features they are
not behaved NIAID essentially one of the
biggest assumption in the hidden Markov
model in terms of tri-series forecast in
pouring into duper strapping stress
period to backpacks and last and not
least is that it really compliance so
method two is is a financial regulation
they recently released that o algo
trading or algorithm native to consider
first consider does it create a
disorderly market which is really lack
of in here so i already seen the
scientist just my time here is up for
five minutes
thank you very much again it can if you
have any question or if anything so you
can discuss i'm reopen for it it's my
email if you find me on lincoln thank
you very much
[Applause]